we both did Kevin Hart's new series what
the fit yes and it's this is for YouTube
and it is mine was a lot of fun and I'm
told you had a lot of fun I do too with
Kevin Hart I did I know curious because
he is a competitive guy when he is yes
which you wouldn't think but he really
is well you know as well he tried to
play this mind game with you know cuz
pride is one of the things that really
affects man I mean all you got to do is
say I bet you you won't and you said I
will and so he's with him guys that are
like you know I'm small so I can do this
better than you you know that's a
different kind of mentality for me I'm
not being big was supposed to be the
whole day but for him he's like I'm
small so now I'm better mind trick he's
also he's takes his fitness very very
seriously and so he's really into it and
I we have a clip what was it that you
were doing with him you were doing
gymnastics gymnastics yes that's why it
was like I'm small and I'm better oh
come on man let's take a look at this
clip from what the fit Kevin Hart and
Terry Crews let's take a look right now
you need upper-body strength okay Terry
will go with the big rings
be careful Terry let me go now push -
there we go there we go push elbow
straight
[Music]
[Music]
pasen you look amazing
but what you don't know it took me two
weeks to recover from nails like my arms
are still shivering you must weigh three
times as much as Kevin Hart it was crazy
I mean yeah you should like grab onto a
butterfly and float up you know you
should you should have him on a show
where you get stopped up a high shelf
you